who's that you must be new that is first
wayne this away Clark Kent Daily Planet
what's your position on the bat
vigilante in Gotham civil liberties have
been trampled on in your city people
living in fear thinks he's above the law
The Daily Planet criticizing those who
think they're above the laws who
hypocrite for what you say considering
every time your hero saves the cat out
of a tree you read off-piste editorial
about an alien you could burn the whole
place down most of the world doesn't
share your opinion mr. Wayne maybe
Gotham City and me you just have a bad
history with freaks dressed like clowns
boys hmm Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I
love it I love bringing people together
how are we Thanks hi hello Lex it is a
pledge out wow that is a good grip you
should not pick a fight with this person
you know the oldest lion America senator
the power can be innocent
you're gonna go to war
as savage brought the war to us
you know you can't win this it's suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world Son of Krypton
versus bat of Gotham you're psychotic
it's a three-syllable word for any
thought too big for little minds it's
time you learned what it means to be a
man
I wanted it you'll be dead already
man won't kill god
yeah we'll do it
what have you done
ha
she would you I thought she was with you
you
hey youtubers is charlie so new Batman
vs Superman footage essentially
confirming that doomsday is going to be
in the movie let's break it down so the
big thing about this trailer is that it
teases the confrontation like we
actually get scenes with Batman and
Superman talking to each other and Lex
Luthor and Wonder Woman I thought she
was with you I thought she was with you
doomsday is the big news though now
because it looks like they use odds body
to create this crazy monster you could
think of him as a version of bizarro but
but i think his village is just meant to
invoke doomsday just because of the
protrusions you don't get man to kill
god you get God to kill God the crazy
thing about this is that the death of
superman ark the ark that introduced
doomsday was what got me started reading
comics in the 90s like that was like the
first big comic book arc I ever read let
me know let me know if you guys have
actually read that and if you haven't
you should definitely check it out I
mean it's a deep cut but it's really big
it's one of the biggest things they ever
did to the character post crisis on
Infinite Earths we get a little bit more
context for some of these fight scenes
between Batman and Superman it looks
like Batman uses his bat wing to go
after Superman bit of a longer fight in
the armor sack Snyder actually said
something cool about the Batman armor he
said that it's not so much to help him
fight Superman is just to give him a
couple extra seconds before he gets
crushed like a soda can by Superman the
real question is what is Lex Luthor due
to Zod's body to turn him into this
doomsday character it looks like it has
something to do with the Kryptonite but
remember there's still a lot of
Kryptonian tech that was left on earth
like Superman didn't go around and clean
all that up after the big battle so Lex
Luthor prolly got his hands on a bunch
of Zod stuff there is a lot of classic
Superman's story in here to Lex Luthor
trying to use Superman's strength
against him in past movies he's used
kryptonite in this movie it's going to
be a much more literal thing like we'll
be able to turn around and punch this
because it's a much bigger threat than
either of us are like I like the way
Bruce Wayne shades Clark can for the
quote unquote puff pieces that he writes
every time Superman saves a kitten from
a tree basically calling him the
shittiest journalist in Metropolis I
also love the reference to the Joker
when he talks about a clown in a suit we
haven't had very much luck in our town
with clowns and suits just looking at
the collateral damage of the dead Robin
but now we know what's going to bring
them together at the end of the film and
if Lex Luthor can create one doomsday
then he could probably do a whole bunch
of other stuff just
tip of the iceberg yeah Lex Luthor kind
of a villa in this film probably gonna
continue to be a big villain in the DC
Universe but by the time we get to
Justice League just expect the threat to
get bigger and bigger like if it takes
the Holy Trinity to take down doomsday
and they add the flash cyborg a bunch of
their caters like Aquaman then they're
going to need a much bigger villain so
here's my big question for you guys what
do you think about the look of doomsday
in this movie and which villain do you
think that they can get to top this for
the Justice League movie down the road
my thought is that they could do a
version of Brainiac like Lex Luthor
trying to co-opt Kryptonian technology
that could be where Brainiac comes from
but even if he comes from outer space
it'll still have to be alien tech they
kind of did a version of that with
Ultron in age of Ultron were like he was
born out of a [ __ ] our program so I
don't know necessarily that they go the
exact same round and Batman vs Superman
the Brainiac is just like the easiest go
to for much bigger big bad in the next
film don't forget they haven't been
talking about it a whole lot but there
is going to be a man of steel to
eventually so even though they're going
to have all these big team up movies we
can have a solo Batman trilogy there'll
be another solo Superman film too for
those of you that are asking about where
the other Justice League members are in
this film supposedly Aquaman in the
flash like the other minor members are
just going to be mentioned very very
small president the film like don't
blink because you'll miss them because
this is really all about bringing Batman
and Superman together and then bringing
Wonder Woman in the mix it kind of
sounds like the first time they run into
doomsday together they don't even know
that diana is Wonder Woman like they
haven't even seen her before but based
on what we know about the Wonder Woman
movie that goes back all the way to
World War one so one woman's been around
for a long time just watching things
unfold in case you missed it though the
Wonder Woman movie has been shooting
there just hasn't been a lot of talk
about it recently congratulations to the
winner of my batman giveaway cecil
joseph you win a gift certificate for a
batman-themed Funko you basically just
pick any one you want off of amazon so
be sure to private message me on the
back end of my channel so I get your
contact info and if you guys didn't know
I just posted my arrow video from the
arrow flash crossover there's a reverse
flash ring giveaway that's going on and
that's all I'll add some links in the
description so why you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click
here for the arrow video from the arrow
flash crossover from tonight and you can
click here for all my Batman vs Superman
videos thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight